hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge
master builders weil ich kann das so gut
ihr wisst ja ich komme nahezu jedem
themengebiet hier unglaublich gut klar
und habe auch echt komplette
und hier wie zu heiligen scheiße soll
man eine rentier bauen die die youtuber
neben diesem modus unglaublich ernst und
bauen hier echt komplette kunstwerke hin
zu denen leider nicht gesehen
ich weiß noch übernehmen wie beim
masters das kommentieren wieso nehmen
ist überhaupt auf denn ich master bilder
spiele bin ich auch immer mit zu leuten
im chat die dann so richtig motiviert
sind der play3 de schreibt
beispielsweise also ich habe auf jeden
fall verloren
ich aber auch verloren man sieht ja echt
unglaublich scheiße aus wir haben lange
auf diesen moment gewartet nun ist es
endlich soweit mehrere jahre minecraft
anbau erfahrungen sammelten sich
zusammen um dieses eine kunstwerk zu
machen es ist nichts anderes als das
sagenumwobene unfassbar tolle nicht zu
unterschätzende
komm mal runter
die assistenten die kiste der kiste ist
jetzt locker ins und brief für mich drin
sagt luca 9 kann ich eigentlich aus der
map irgendwie abcheck klo
ach da waren die anderen ihre sachen
oder wie viele sagen das master will das
bei mir keinen spaß macht aber ich finde
nicht sondern redet hier auf die beine
stelle
da macht es keinen spaß übrigens bin ich
krank deswegen bin ich ein bisschen
aggressiv und dumm
andere youtuber brauchen so wirklich
fünf minuten komplett um ihre sachen
fertig zu bauen ich bin immer schon nach
einer minute fertig und gewinnt das ding
trotzdem okay
ich gewiss doch nicht der ist hier sieht
auf jeden fall ganz geil aus ich komme
mir nie auf die idee das ganze auch in
diesem marmor staind schon wieder so ein
tolles leben tiere man jetzt habe ich in
dem ersten slot red state clay gott
selbst das hier ist noch schöner als
mainz wenn der hier auch eine failed ich
will nicht wissen was sie zum einen
sagen das ist tatsächlich doch auch voll
süß guck mal so kenne ich bin raus
dieses rentier hatte sehr dünne beine
und sieht aber eigentlich ganz süß aus
eigentlich seines also ich muss wirklich
sagt der bauer von diesem rentier muss
jan kompletter spaß ich bin mir
überhaupt nicht sicher aber alle
schreiben so wtf von fragezeichen und
den cds murmeln login
wie folgt dar
jetzt ist eigentlich nur noch die frage
ob ich letzter oder vorletzter werde ich
denke mal letzter dir hat wieder einer
das thema komplett missverstanden
es ging um rentiere wenn man denkt es
geht nicht immer kommt nochmal besonnen
ist ein feld und hier ist einfach eine
hütte da war die hütte die sah wie man
bedenkt dass wir sogar rentiere ich bin
letzte alles klar ich habe mir
eigentlich gedacht dass ich noch eine
zweite runde dranhänge weil ich gerade
echtzeit habe aber wenn ich letzter
werden urlaub ich auch keinen bock drauf
jeden tunnel exception ja vario
exception eine vorhandene verbindung
wurde vom remote ausgeschlossen
die hamburger auch kein bock mehr auf
mich an dieser stelle muss ich das video
beenden da warte ich glaube ich weiß
woran es liegt das video jetzt damit
will ich sagen ich habe einfach die tür
immer noch offen das war es von diesem
video wenn es euch gefallen hat auch die
soft pop steht auch komplett anders dass
es im entscheid kanal also erwartet
keine qualitäts wehrt euch das video
gefallen hat dann
hat es ähnlich oder zeigt es mir mit
einer bewertung und klickt auf die
werbung und kauft mein merchandise
heraus zu lachen das ist das beste
marketing